a recent CBS News poll finds 40% of
Americans plan to make New Year's
resolutions retired Navy SEAL David
Goggin says he knows how to make those
changes stick Goggins is described as
one of the toughest men on the planet
he's the only man in history to complete
elite training as a Navy SEAL Army
Ranger and Air Force tactical air
controller
he's also an ultra marathon runner with
more than 60 races under his belt
Goggins has published a memoir and
self-help book called can't hurt me
master your mind and defy the odds this
morning it's number 2 on Amazon's
nonfiction charts behind only Michelle
Obama's becoming he shares his journey
from living in poverty to surviving SEAL
training and how you can reach your full
potential and David is with us this
morning good morning morning so this 40%
jumps out to me as you say only 40% of
our true potentials what most of us are
using how do you get to that number
well the whole thing about is that your
your mind has the ultimate tactical
advantage over you yes it knows your
insecurities knows your fears and knows
your self-doubts and those all those
creepy spots to stay clear of so our
mind keeps us from those spots so the
whole 40% rule was oscillating my whole
life kind of going away from those spots
that made me very uncomfortable because
I'm you know my mind was saying you're
not good here you're not good there more
than half the time more than half the
time so happens is we when you get in
these situations where you need more
it's like a car our car has a governor
so you know some cars have governor's on
yeah that's it yeah they can go 130 but
the governor said 492 so you're sitting
there trying to race a Corvette the
Corvette flies by but you're like god I
was just governor was off our brain has
a governor also yeah whenever it gets to
those fears those insecurities those
those issues that we haven't dealt with
in life the governor comes on and we
can't go past that you write that
motivation is crap it's crap yes right
what do you mean what motivation is
kindling so basically what it is is I
made more debate some people a day for
this four minutes I'm on TV
yep oh my god we'll go do something do
that great but let's say it's real cold
out in New York City let's say it's 30
degrees you go outside you get your
gloves on you go for
run you're gonna forget everything you
said is gone yeah that's motivation so
you're right about how rocky motivated
you that's right will be motivated you
but had to take it that next step so how
do you do that then well the thing about
it is it's about being driven almost to
the point where you're obsessed because
when you get to that point of being
driven and possibly obsessed you no
longer care if it's 30 degrees outside
you that that that windchill hit your
face you feel it you might go back
inside but to get more clothes on to go
outside so you find that that that
passion that purpose of your life is
different everybody a lot of tragedy
happen in your life early on and and the
death of a potential stepdad you
witnessed a young child that was
tragically killed in an accident but
there was something that hit me you talk
about being the only one of your kind
many many times and that all you want to
do is stay home and wallow because to go
to go into public is to be completely
exposed vulnerable or a world the tracks
and judges you right it's just as simple
as that
it's as simple as that basically what
you have to do is just look at yourself
in the mirror we are always a lot of
bunch of waiting for this magical thing
to happen and fix our lives like for
instance a lot of things damage my life
it wouldn't just all me you know
it's your dad it's your mom it's your
childhood it's a it's being bullied it's
so many things that we all have a story
but what happens is we're always sitting
in I call it poopy pants loopy ping
poopy pants we're all sitting back what
was me kicking rocks down the street
yeah we're waiting for some magical
miracle to happen for know to get fixed
and that's not going to happen and jump
out of your comfort zone you have to do
that you have to face all these things
because it's not all yours to own Matt
what happened how do you make that how
do you make that move well how you do it
first is I call it the accountability
mirror mm-hmm when I was 16 17 years old
I went to this mirror looked at myself
in the mirror and I saw a person that I
wasn't proud of mm-hmm
you have to call yourself out you wanted
to be proud of yourself what are you
proud of myself you have to call
yourself out in a way that's not kind
we live in a very kind gentle world we
have to find the right words for
situations you have to call yourself out
for what it is and change the problem
he's me real with you so real or wrong
with yourself to fix the problem I just
have to ask you cuss a lot in this bar I
do
why because my life wasn't nice it was
what I wanted I want to paint a real
picture I don't want to try to say oh
let me not say this and I may offend you
life offended me all right had to
overcome it and and you can read all
about it David thank you so much we
appreciate it can't hurt me on sale now
you can find it wherever you buy your
books